- [Kelly[ Oh my gosh, first of all,
your hair is my favorite thing...
- Oh, thank you.
- [Kelly] of the year.
Oh my God, it's gorgeous.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] That natural curl, good Lord.
Everyone, I have to say this,
everyone compared the Covid,
like the whole pandemic,
to your movie Groundhog Day.
- [Andie MacDowell] Yes, I saw that a lot.
- [Kelly] What it was like for you?
- [Andie MacDowell] Oh, wow.
Yeah, I mean, what a crazy time, huh?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- Yeah, I was,...
I live, I live alone.
And I was bleaching absolutely everything.
I don't know why.
- [Kelly] You were just scared.
- You know, I mean, we were
bleaching all our groceries
as they came in.
Do you remember the crazy
things that we were doing?
- It was crazy spraying down everything,
trusting no individual.
- But I don't know what I
thought it was gonna accomplish,
because, you know, it was just the,
the cats coming in, maybe.
I don't know.
But it was like on the
floor, bleaching everything.
- [Kelly] I know.
- I think made us feel safe.
Somehow, it made us feel
like we were doing something.
- [Kelly] I know, it was a
very boring time for a lot
of us, yeah.
- [Andie MacDowell] A way to control.
I did drink a little bit much.
- [Kelly] Yeah. - Too much.
- [Kelly] I think all of us did, Andie.
It was a very weird time for a lot of us.
But yeah, you're from
the South, obviously.
- Yes. - [Kelly] I love
your accent so much.
- Where are you from?
- [Kelly] I'm from Fort Worth, Texas.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
We're Fort Worth and Burleson, both place,
but in Texas.
- [Andie MacDowell] A lot of
people think I'm from Texas,
but I' not.
I'm from South Carolina.
- [Kelly] So, I love South Carolina.
- [Andie MacDowell] Yeah, it's nice.
- Yeah. - [Andie MacDowell] Yeah.
- It's beautiful.
- Yeah. - [Kelly] Yeah.
So did you grow up with, I
heard, a bit of a potty mouth?
- I didn't grow up with a potty mouth.
I became...
- [Kelly] When did it happen?
- In my mature years.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- I became very dirty, just horrible.
And I was, I was relieved
to hear that you do that.
- Yeah.
- Because to me, you
seem sort of angelic,...
- [Kelly] Well,...
- and pure.
- [Kelly] You know what it made...
That's so nice.
Um, it made...
Don't you laugh, Weiss.
(distant audience chuckling)
Weiss has known me for like over a decade.
- [Andie MacDowell] But
that's, that's your image.
- [Kelly] No, no, I am that,
but I just, I also was a cocktail waitress
And, "darn it" it just doesn't cover it.
It doesn't cover the ground.
- [Andie MacDowell] Dadgummit!
- [Kelly] Yeah, that doesn't cover it.
- No.
- Now, my mom's not excited
about it, but it just,
yeah it's still here.
It just feels good to say
(background tonal beeping)
sometimes, you know?
(distant audience laughing)
- [Andie MacDowell] But can
you, what do you do on daytime?
You bleep it...
- [Kelly] You don't, you
don't, they edit that out,
or bleep.
I don't know what they're gonna do.
I'll probably loose viewers,
but I'll gain a whole new kind audience.
So, it's fine.
But no, but sometimes....
- [Andie MacDowell] I relate to...
- it just feels good.
- [Andie MacDowell] Yes, and you know,
can say the words I really like?
- [Kelly] Go for...
- [Andie MacDowell] Yeah, I did say,
I made rat's ass.
- [Speakers] I don't give a rat's ass.
- [Andie MacDowell] I
don't give a rat's ass.
- [Kelly] That's southern.
- I had a friend who used to say that.
And she's such a classy lady.
That I thought, you know,
"That's cool I say that."
- [Kelly] We're covered.
- I'm, I'm terrible, because I say...
(background tonal beeping)
a lot.
- [Kelly] Me too.
(distant audience laughing)
'Cause it feels good.
But I do feel like we're safe,
because I don't even know if
she wants everybody to know
this, but Dolly Parton is like,...
Okay, she's like the most
perfect person on the planet.
I love Dolly Parton.
She's the nicest human ever.
Amazing, but kind of a sailor.
- [Andie MacDowell] I love that.
- Like, like a bit of a sailor.
And it made me feel good.
- That I have anything in
common with her just makes me...
Particularly this area,
I feel okay about it.
- [Kelly] I know, I feel
like if she's doing it,
and she's like, so
beloved, it's, we're fine.
- Yeah, we're good.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(distant audience applauding)
- So her new series is
called The Way Home,
and you can see it's starting
Sunday on Hallmark Channel.
So can you tell us a
little about The Way Home?
- Oh, wow.
It's, um,...
When I read the script, I
really fell in love with it.
I loved my character,
because she takes care of bees.
Like she, you know, she has bees,
and she gives back to her community,
and she lives on this gorgeous farm,
and she's sort of the salt of the earth.
But then it becomes very
mystical, and magical.
And Chyler Leigh plays my daughter.
It's multi-generational.
Sadie Laflamme-Snow
plays my granddaughter.
So it's three generations,
which I also appreciate
as a woman that...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Andie MacDowell] You know?
And, um, it's a family drama,
but more than a family drama.
Something happens.
I don't wanna tell you what happens.
- [Kelly] No spoilers.
- [Andie MacDowell] Yeah
yeah, can't do that.
But I will tell you, I had to play two,
I had to play myself in 1999.
And that was a little scary,
because, you know, I'm an older woman.
- Yeah.
- And, um, we did some stuff with makeup.
And I wear a wig, and everything.
And they use a, a hustle blend, um, lens,
which is a portrait
lens that gives kind of
a diffused, matte...
It gave sort of a magical feeling.
- [Kelly] I think I've seen them do this,
like in films with people, yeah.
- Yeah. - Yeah.
- Anyway, but you know, at the same time,
I had to think about how I sounded,
and what is my body like?
Because you walk different.
- [Kelly] That's hard.
- And I had to, you know,
really was like my arms,
you know, because they change.
And...
- Yeah.
- all those kinds of things.
So that, you know, was
interesting as an actress,
but also a little bit scary.
- [Kelly] Absolutely,...
- Yeah.
So that was fun, and challenging.
- [Kelly] I don't know
if anyone's noticed,
my body's real different from 20.
Like, I'm like...
(distant audience laughing)
- But I wasn't 20, not 20,
I was 20 years younger.
So let's say I would be
playing 40, you know?
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- Sixties, and forty.
- [Kelly] Okay, right on.
- But still, that's,
you know, that's a jump.
- [Kelly] It's different.
So the series you said it,
it deals with generational
kind of things, so
generational trauma as well.
- Generational trauma is a big part of...
- [Kelly] Which I feel like everyone has.
- the story.
- Everyone can relate
a little bit to that.
- [Andie MacDowell] Oh, for sure.
And I think we've become
much more conscious
about what that is.
- [Kelly] And open, yeah.
- And open, and healthy.
It's really healthy.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Andie MacDowell] To, to
talk about these things.
But there is a lot of pain that exists.
It's interesting, my
relationship with my daughter is,
um, we, we, it's a very
troubled relationship.
There's a lot of healing
that needs to be done.
And I haven't really had
time with my granddaughter,
because of this.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Um,...
And, um, I really loved playing that,...
the idea of finally having a relationship
with the granddaughter.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because I can relate to that.
I just had my first grandchild.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's exciting.
- And I know what that feels like.
And I can't imagine,
I thought about that when I
was developing this character.
What it would feel like to
have not had that relationship.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To have it, to have it kept from me.
Um,...
So there's so many layers
to the story that are really
beautiful, and were really
interesting to play.
And I loved working with these actresses.
They did such a good job.
- [Kelly] It's cool to work
with, like, different ages too.
Like all, it's just different
experiences coming together.
- Yes, exactly. - Be on a film.
Yeah. - Yeah.
- [Kelly] A different
kind of chemistry of it.
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I feel like everyone
has generational trauma.
I feel like in some form or, you know,
whatever it is in your world.
Did you ever, what was your relationship
with your mother since you're
playing the mother in...
- Oh, yeah.
Well, I had a very sort of
codependent relationship
with my mother.
She was an alcoholic, and, um,...
- [Kelly] Wow, that's hard.
- [Andie MacDowell] Yeah, it was hard.
She played the organ at church.
I mean, she would go to church.
And we would be playing the organ,
and we'd just be like, "Oh my
God, is she gonna make it?"
I mean, it was sad.
It was really sad.
And I ended up working.
She was a teacher,
but she couldn't keep those jobs.
And she kept losing them.
She kept changing schools,
and eventually ended up
working in McDonald's.
And I worked at McDonald's with her.
And, um...
- Do you think you chose to do that, to,
for a reason?
- I was just happy to have a job.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- Yeah, I wanted to make money.
- [Kelly] 'Cause you
noticed that she wasn't like
keeping a job?
- No. - Oh, okay.
- No, that wasn't, that wasn't it.
But she had lost her driver's license.
She had a couple of DUIs.
And I was driving her to work
on the day that she lost her
job, because she wasn't sober enough.
And it was just, you know, it
was a lot of responsibility to
make that call.
Like, I thought she was sober enough.
I mean, that was my, kind
of, my job was to decide...
- [Kelly] And you want to
believe in your parent,
you wanna believe in that right?
- [Andie MacDowell] It wasn't even that.
I mean, no.
- [Kelly] No?
- No, I mean, I, I really was
taking care of her, honestly.
I mean, it was me trying
to figure out if she was
sober enough, and I felt really guilty...
- That's a lot on a kid.
- [Andie MacDowell] A lot, it's a lot.
- Yeah.
- [Andie MacDowell] It's a lot to say,
"Oh, maybe you should call in."
I just didn't think of it.
Anyway, she got fired.
And I asked for them to
give her her job back.
But they didn't, so I quit.
Which was...
- [Kelly] solidarity. - Yeah.
- You were like, "Well,
then I'm going too."
- Yeah, what could I do?
Wasn't going to stay after they fired her.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So,...
- I think what's interesting too,
is when I have, like, my
own abandonment issues,
like things going in my life....
But I think what's interesting
is how you perceive it
as a child, and how you accept things,
and you don't know it was
kind of wrong, or not cool.
And then you have kids,
and you go,...
"How in the world could
you walk away from a child?
How in the world could you
not want to be involved?"
It's an interesting thing to have kids,
and have a completely
different perspective on your
childhood, because of their childhood.
- [Andie MacDowell] Mhmmm.
- [Kelly] You know what
I'm saying? - Mhmmm.
- [Kelly] And then it's kind of cool too,
because it's like, all
right, I know what not to do.
I know it didn't work, at
least for me when I was a kid.
So, I'm gonna try, and do better.
- I know I got a lot of things
better than what I received,
because I was able to make improvements.
But I talked to my kids about
making their own improvements,
because...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't feel like I
got everything, for sure.
- [Kelly] And no one does.
If you're saying so, you're a liar.
- Yeah. - So,...
- But I think I made vast
improvements on what I,
my experience was.
But also, it's such a different time,
because we talk about all this now.
And this was not anything that was ever...
We didn't speak about
these kinds of things.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And, um,...
You know, my mother had shock
treatments after I was born.
She, she had what they would've
called a nervous breakdown.
It could have been partially postpartum.
So many things that it could have been.
And she was diagnosed with
schizophrenia, so she,
you know, she was, had a lot of trouble.
- Yeah.
- [Andie MacDowell] And it,...
was not able to get the
care that she needed to get,
because of the time.
- [Kelly] Which is why
it's so important now
that we're talking about stuff like this,
so people have access,
and opportunity to care.
- [Andie MacDowell] So, so, so important.
But anyway, to get back to
my, to my beautiful children,
I did, I took this course on parenting.
And one of the...
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- [Andie MacDowell] Yeah, yeah.
And one of the things
they taught us, like,
they asked like people in
the audience who were saying,
"What do you think is the
most important thing you do
for your child?"
And they were like, "Oh,
to make them be empathetic,
to want to give back to their community."
And all these beautiful things...
And, and he was like, "Yes,
all these things are really beautiful,
but what the most important
thing that you can
give your child is to
make them independent,
so they can fly."
You know?
- Yeah.
- It's like, "Oh, well that makes sense."
Is to make them inde...
Mine have flown away.
- [Kelly] Yeah? - Mine flew away.
- You've done a great job then.
That's why I'm not a helicopter mom.
I'm very independent with them.
- [Andie MacDowell] Yes.
- Like, I, I think I was raised like that.
So I think that's important.
- [Andie MacDowell] Yeah.
- Because then by the time
they're, they are flying away
you feel like they're, you
know, prepared for that.
- [Andie MacDowell] Yeah.
- It's scary.
- [Andie MacDowell] Mine
definitely flew the coop.
- [Kelly] Yeah? - Yeah, they...
- [Kelly] So you nailed it, way to go.
- I know.
- Killed it! - I know.
(distant audience applauding)